it's just after 8 30 on Monday morning
in Louisville Kentucky
officers approaching the bank they know
a gunman is inside
they'd been dispatched just three
minutes earlier
and as they approached the door from
inside they're targeted officer Nicholas
Wilt just 26 and on his fourth shift
with the police is hit
the other officer Falls
with backup in place
the gunman is hit I think he's down
another American mass shooting brought
to an end
the five victims all worked at the bank
James Tutt Juliana farmer Diana erket
Tommy Elliott and Joshua Barrick
officer Wilt is now in a critical
condition in hospital
at a news conference city officials were
full of emotion anger disbelief I'm
weary there's only so many times you can
walk into a room
and tell someone they're not coming home
tomorrow
this isn't about partisan politics
this is about life
and death
this is about preventing tragedies
the raid on the gunman's home was itself
a reflection of America police units
militarized the response to violence so
prevalent in society here inside we're
told They seized evidence
he was Connor sturgeon 25 years old an
employee of the bank a colleague of
those he would kill he bought the
assault style AR-15 rifle legally at a
dealer in the city last week and in a
country which has seen 147 mass
shootings this year alone here's another
fact Kentucky law requires the murder
weapon not be destroyed but sold at
auction back onto the open market Mark
Stone Sky News in Washington